let's turn to another major crisis
caused by the biden administration
in may border patrol tallied a record
number of migrant encounters 239
thousand in just one month alone
the situation is so dire that multiple
texas counties listen to this have now
formally declared this crisis an
invasion
joining us now with more is fox news
contributor sarah carter along with the
president of the national border patrol
council brandon judd
okay so now what we've got brandon i'll
start with you
is that by declaring it an invasion
several of these counties in
in texas and i believe in arizona as
well believe that under their
constitution
that declaring it an invasion allows for
the states to then engage in a situation
where without the approval of congress
they can make it take it upon themselves
to actually handle those immigrants and
return them to mexico
what say you
yeah this clearly shows how bad the
states are feeling right now as far as
the the crisis goes these counties are
not republican counties if you look at
two of them valverde and maverick county
they're democrat counties and they
clearly know that they are shouldering
the burden of everything that's going on
as far as illegal immigration goes they
have to deal with all the drownings it's
not the federal government that steps in
and takes care of those bodies it's the
counties that have to do it they have to
deal with all of the drugs that are
coming in it's not the federal
government it's the counties they have
to deal with the crime they know that
this situation can be controlled but
it's going to take the white house's
support to get it done and the white
house just isn't doing anything about it
so the states are now having to step in
they're having to look at how they can
exercise their authorities under the
constitution and and i'm hoping that the
states are willing to do everything that
they can and and let it go to the courts
let the courts determine whether or not
the states can in fact do this as long
as they do what they can it will it will
shine the spotlight on what needs to be
done well you know you have to give
attorney general mark brnovich
some credit for this he read the state
constitution and he read it as opening
up a number of potential legal avenues
that can certainly be ruled on by the
courts but sarah carter you've been at
the border for years
i visited the border many many times
what is different about the border
during joe biden's administration
compared to other administrations
well it's run with absolute impunity as
far as we're dealing with the drug
cartels i think brandon can attest to
that or the human trafficking
organizations it is wide open our border
patrol agents their hands have been tied
behind their back they don't have the
authority they once had
basically president biden just
overturned every single executive order
that was put in place by president trump
that really was the first time in my
time covering the border judge that i
actually saw action being taken on the
border that was actually effective where
people remained in mexico where people
were being able to be returned back
where the drug cartels and the human
traffickers knew this was the end of the
road for them as soon as president biden
came into office he announced that the
border would be open once again he
allowed people to come through just last
month in may 55 000 godaways that's what
they estimate godways known godaways
came into the country those were people
that were not apprehended and think
about this over 800 000 since president
biden came into office that's unheard of
and another factor that i think is
really important here
i've heard a lot more than eight hundred
thousand we had three hundred thousand
left oh absolutely but that's
but that's known god aways that's just
known that's just people they know have
escaped into the country and you're
absolutely right judge and over 500
deaths just this year alone of migrants
not even including the hundred thousand
americans that have died with drug
overdoses well in fact as it relates to
that brandon the united nations has
issued a declaration
that the deadliest area
in the world is the area between uh
from the central american countries to
the united states they basically say
this u.n migration study deems the u.s
mexican border the deadliest land route
in the world based on the 2021 numbers
they're not even at the 2022 numbers
yeah we're the greatest country in the
world and you would never know it by
those figures right there and what we're
seeing is just complete and total chaos
and it's a disregard from this
administration let's hope that congress
is willing to step up let's hope that
congress is going to pass laws they
close all of these loopholes because we
know that this administration isn't
going to do it no we need people that
are in congress you're going to have
somebody like jim layman who's going to
be on who would be willing to close all
everything that we need to get done if
we have the proper legislation we can do
it if we had policy if this white house
would actually give us the policies like
president trump did as sarah carter
alluded to we could control what's going
on we just can't do it under this white
house right now right and as i said
sarah carter attorney general mark
brnovich was the one who came up with
this idea of basically uh creating that
a situation where a state can engage in
defensive actions within its own
territory or near the border
caused by these transnational cartels
and gangs
one hundred percent attorney general
brnovich has done an incredible job you
know he's being sued right now by the
biden administration basically saying
that you know the button administration
doesn't want people to have ids to
actually vote he's like take me take me
to court let's go all the way to the
supreme court and i agree with him and i
think that's what we need we need more
people like him more people like ken
paxton the attorney general more people
that are challenging this because we can
do it and it's actually very important
for the american people to understand
this is not just the border judge janine
we have so much fentanyl pouring across
that border but it's coming across the
country it's killing our young people
it's killing our citizens we also have
people being migrated across this
country and that is on the taxpayer dime
that is on taxpayer dollars and it is a
national security issue with over 50
people connected to known terrorist
organizations that we have apprehended
at that border this is a serious crisis
it's one that is the responsibility of
the president of the united states and
the executive branch that is their main
authority the main authority given to
the executive branch and to the
president the commander-in-chief is to
protect u.s citizens and he's not doing
it exactly sara carter brandon judd
thank you so much for being with us this
evening and hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else